hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about insulin
resistance potassium and blood pressure
out of all the nutrients that you need
potassium is something needed in very
large quantities you need 4700
milligrams of potassium every single day
now what does that mean with food it
means that hardly anyone is getting the
potassium because you would need 7 to 10
cups of vegetables every single day okay
so how many cups vegetables do you
consume in a given day maybe five maybe
less but I do it because I feel so much
different but here's the thing we need
four times as much potassium as we do
sodium okay most people consume four
times as much sodium as they do
potassium they have a lot of fluid
retention so they both work together in
relationship to fluids and hydration but
we need if you look at vegetable content
it's always heavy on the potassium and
very low in the sodium okay but if
you're doing like chips and salty things
that's going to that's going to throw
this whole thing off so what happens
when you have low potassium as you get
high blood pressure potassium is the
physiological relaxer it calms the
nervous system it actually softens the
arteries it actually can prevent strokes
it's very very healthy healthy mineral
and so it can also prevent constipation
it also can prevent leg cramps so it's
involved in nerve conductivity and
muscle contraction and relaxation so
with a problem with potassium you can
have a lot of cramps tightness and
tension in your body and you can also
have a lot of electrical problems with
your heart arrhythmias atrial fib that's
all potassium deficiency because people
don't consume enough so let's pretend
that you're you have high blood pressure
and you have to take a diuretic thiazide
well what that does is it gets rid of
fluid well it does it also gets rid of
potassium so what happens when you take
this diuretic to fix your high blood
pressure you lose more potassium raising
the blood pressure more so now you
and then you're told to drink more water
which dilutes the electrolytes more
especially potassium and your blood
pressure goes higher because more water
is not going to hydrate you it's going
to get rid of the electrolytes that you
have potassium specifically and you
don't get the hydration you once had so
the whole myth of drinking more water to
hydrate you is not quite true you need
the minerals that specifically potassium
that's the one you need in the most
amount like even magnesium you need
about four hundred and twenty milligrams
but potassium maybe 4700 okay now also
if your salt sensitive okay especially
if your blood pressure what that really
means is your potassium deficient the
way to fix people that are salt
sensitive is just increased potassium
and they'll do fine so instead of
restricting salt why don't we just
increase potassium it's a better
strategy because if you need potassium
for other things 98 percent of all the
potassium in your body is inside the
cell not outside the cell so when you
get tests tested from your blood or
whatever testing you do it's very
difficult to test the potassium
deficiency because it's all inside the
cell and so you might you might think
you have normal levels that you really
don't because you never did it
intracellular test for potassium okay
the other interesting thing about
potassium if it takes insulin to control
and absorb potassium if you don't have
enough insulin
you can't pull potassium in the cells
so insulin regulates potassium now how
does that relate to a pre-diabetic
someone has insulin resistance or a
diabetic well if they have insulin
resistance they're going to have the
cells are going to block insulin so
guess what's going to happen the
potassium they're not going to have
enough potassium so a lot of times when
you have a pre-diabetic or DUP like even
a diabetic state they have a huge huge
deficiency of potassium and one of the
things I make sure that they
do is greatly increase the vegetable
content to increase the potassium to
help balance this thing out because
there's going to have you're gonna have
so many side effects from that so if you
actually add more potassium you can
decrease the need for insulin so that's
a really cool relationship I just wanted
to touch on the relationship between
these two these three items right here
and if you have blood pressure start
increasing your vegetables and if you
like this kind of information if you
like learning about nutrition if you
find it interesting I have a health
coaching training program that you might
be interested in learning about where we
teach you a lot more about nutrition and
how the body works so if you want to
apply to the scholarship that I have
click the link below check it out study
it and maybe you can be a health coach
as well thanks for watching